in 1832 mathematician Carl Gauss and
physics professor William Weber designed
a system which allowed them to
communicate at a distance while they
worked on their experiments connecting
the observatory with the physical
laboratory they solved a really
important problem which was more of a
puzzle how to send all letters of the
alphabet using one circuit or a line and
their system used a galvanometer since
it was known that electric current
passing through a coil creates a
magnetic field pointing through the
center of the loop which could deflect a
needle but instead of merely moving a
needle at a distance their system used a
switch which could reverse the direction
of current instantly this would cause
the magnetic field around the coil to
reverse and the needle would deflect
either to the right or left depending on
the direction of current thus giving
them two different signaling events or
symbols right or left deflection most
importantly he assigned shorter symbols
for the most common letters such as a
was a single right deflection and E was
a single left deflection and he used the
longer codes for less common letters
such as K which was three right
deflections and at the time the speed of
transmission was around nine letters per
minute all the needle Telegraph's which
followed suffered from a similar
limitation and it was an engineering
problem
the signalling rate was slow now the
signaling rate was the number of
deflections per minute which could be
accurately transmitted and received and
if you squish signaling events together
the receiver would get confused due to
jitter resulting in errors similar to
how sustained notes on a piano will
bleed together and become less
recognizable if you play rapidly and
over time the signaling rate was
incrementally improved one improvement
was to add a small permanent magnet to
the outside of the coil this helped pull
the needle back to neutral position
after each deflection and these designs
led to a wide range of needle
Telegraph's which were deployed across
Europe the electric telegraph company
was the first public Telegraph company
it was formed in 1846 after its owners
purchased the key needle Telegraph
patents at the time but the speed of
these various needle Telegraph's never
surpassed around 60 letters per minute
as each needle couldn't signal much
faster than one deflection per second
and initially the company billed
customers based on single messages which
could hold up to 20 words which is about
the length of a tweet and by 1848 the
cost of sending a single message from
London to Edinburgh was sixteen
shillings and this was around one week's
salary for say a shop owner at the time
so this technology was initially out of
the hands of common people in the United
States the commercialization of the
Telegraph was led by a portrait painter
named Samuel Morse who had followed
development of the needle Telegraph's in
Europe Moore's is important because he
focused on speeding up the rate at which
letters could travel he did away with
needles and in 1938 he initially
submitted a patent based on the idea
that electric current could either flow
or be interrupted and interruptions
could be organized to create meaning
though his designs on how to produce
these interruptions were complicated
involving a convoluted system of gears
levers and electromagnets however his
system was greatly simplified after his
collaborations with Albert Vail this led
to an iconic piece of user interface the
simple spring-loaded lever or key which
can be controlled with the tap of a
finger and on the receiving end was a
spring-loaded lever that could be pulled
and released by a strong electric
magnet
to create a difference akin to the
left/right deflection he varied the
length of a key press or the pulse width
the closure of a switch for a very short
time was called a dot and the dot can be
thought of as the basic unit of time in
Moore's code and the closure of the
switch for three units of time
represented a dash spacing exactly right
very small typed spaces between the dits
and DAHS and a character did odd it did
I did it and this was the source of
difference in their coding strategy
starting with an initial dot or - left
or right branch which then leads to
another dot or - and so on and the
scheme assigned shorter symbol sequences
- more probable letters based on the
letter frequencies which could be
tabulated from books so nodes high up in
the tree such as a single dot
represented eat a single - represented T
and as we move down the tree we place
less common letters and after a letter
the system inserts a three-unit pause
spacing between the characters in a word
or group is uniform - but longer it's
important to realize that the meaning of
these messages was intertwined with the
timing of them are you wondering if
proper spacing is really so important or
is it no more than an extra refinement
the nice thing to do like neat
handwriting if you think so you're wrong
and I'll show you why it's for debt and
Dada
they match
only the spacing makes the difference
between one word and the other so to
send the word Paris we would first need
to think of it as P space a space R
space I space s the signaling rate of
this system was directly related to the
tempo of the signal and music analogies
were used inside training videos what he
was sending was the standard test word
Paris and there you are each peak is a
dit or a da each valley a space this is
excellent sending uniform and Griffin
this is an example of poor hand sending
same word Paris but look at the
difference irregular dips and odd
haphazard spacing no uniformity no
rhythm amazingly it was the simplicity
of this keying system which made it much
faster than any of the buttons and
cranks employed by the needle
Telegraph's in Europe the letter rate
jumped to 135 letters per minute or more
with trained operators and on May 24th
1844 the first successful transmission
was the message what hath God wrought
and the next day it was reported by the
New York Tribune that quote the miracle
of annihilation of space is at length
performed
consider that at the time 90% of
messages were still transported by
horseback immediately this technology
was becoming critical to the success of
military newspapers financial traders
crime-fighting
any business that relied on information
now relied on the Telegraph and Morse
code by 1900 the prices had dropped to
30 cents per message as traffic surged
to over 60 3.2 million messages sent
that year as people began using this
system they naturally thought of way
to save money this led to popular code
books that mapped words to common
sentences for example blade would
actually mean please name and reserve
for myself and family the following
accommodations the Telegraph companies
frowned upon this as they were happily
charging people to be verbose more
letters equals more profit it was now
clear that information was an elastic
term and a specific meaning was needed
an obvious question remained unanswered
if you are selling information no matter
the system how should you quantify it to
be fair to everyone number of letters as
a measure of information would no longer
suffice